hi hey wow it's awesome to be here
single these smiling faces you might
have seen me around I'm kind of full of
full of energy so I've been doing a lot
of dancing about I am Tim let's just
kind of go through the you know the
admin there's my website there's my
Twitter there's my github there's my
LinkedIn
there's my code pen it's it's it's crazy
actually it's my first time speaking in
Australia these these are my avatars
throughout the last throughout the last
five years and if you do it backwards it
kind of looks like a budding young
software developer slowly start to
question his life choices the software
development not even once
and if it goes forward it's kind of like
my hair is growing growing out which is
nice you may know me from the internet
I've done a ton of stuff I'm always kind
of making five or so years ago I made
this website you would press this button
and it would kind of take you to random
websites online this one's called Elop
calm and you slap a person with simple
web development and I made this website
and got super popular and I was kind of
like whoa I started to get enamored by
things online and I started just wanting
to make things and make things and make
things and make things this is a website
that I have inspiring dot online and I
just kind of post things on there when I
see something fun
I made this font just last year for for
a look written for a js' comfy you it's
called smell vodka it's beautiful you
can install it on your machine and
replace the redundant Helvetica you know
you might have seen these github corners
online they kind of wave when you when
you hover over them that was me it's fun
to see those kind of all over the web
this is something that I made a couple
years ago you kind of scroll down and
you want to go back to the top of the
screen
[Music]
beautiful right you might know me from
my LinkedIn profile full of dog pictures
yeah so I do a lot of stuff online and
today I'm here to talk about generative
art generate vada holds a special place
in my heart because it was kind of the
reason that I got into development in
the first place it kind of provided an
avenue to look at things and make things
without directly kind of comparing
myself to all these fantastic developers
out there and kind of going ah this
websites so good this is so so advanced
why can I kind of do that so back into
the kind of admin stuff generative art
is that in part or whole has been
created with you some autonomous system
and an autonomous system is a system
where it's kind of out of your hands for
example you could roll a dice and do
something different each role and that
is an autonomous system and a speedrun
is a playthrough of a game with the
intention of completing it so I'm going
to teach you how to complete software
development you won't have to do
anything after this but no for me the
speed run aspect of this is to kind of
give you enough information to say hey I
can I can create something like this I
can do it and and and kind of get
everybody on their own making their own
stuff so these are the steps I want to
break it down I want to break down
creating some generator BOTS and I want
to put it into small small pieces that
are very digestible I'm very easy to
understand unlike me because I can't
stop speaking really quickly I want to
show the experimental nature of code and
kind of draw some parallels between
generative art and regular software
development and then finally I want to
kind of get a little bit introspective
this was kind of something that I like
to do in my talks where I put something
together and when you're making a talk
you're thinking so much about all these
aspects of software development and I
can't help myself but then put that in
the talk and a kind of inception thing
it's awesome so I want to introduce this
idea of a tool belt and we use a tool
belt when we're developing always when
you start off you have very few things
in your tool belt and as you get better
and better you kind of have them to draw
upon and you can go oh I know how to do
that I've done it before oh I know how
to do that I've done it before and and
that aspect of programming is just the
reason that I really really like it you
know as time goes on
you build things up in your tool belt so
the first thing that I want to add is a
line this is how you draw a line in
JavaScript there's a little bit of
setting out that I've missed getting the
context but you essentially have two
aspects a stop position and X&Y and
position X&Y and a stroke and I'm
showing a little bit of code in this
talk but not really that much and
nothing really too complex and the
reason for that is really this is just
JavaScript example but there's so many
ways to draw a line on a piece of paper
and if we get all tangled up in that
it's like what are we even doing here so
here's a canvas and here's a line on
there I've drawn it left to right I
could draw that from the diagonal side
to the diagonal side is this generative
art I don't know it's more like a line
on the page so let's just introduce a
little aspect of random math dot random
returns a number between 0 1 so there's
around about 50% chance that it's
greater than half and then we'll have
two splits here we'll draw it maybe from
left to right on one side and from right
to left on the other side so here again
is our line and when I click it's kind
of randomly going from from left to
right is that generative out yet no it's
still just kind of a line on the page so
let's introduce some more techniques and
tiling is the first one and as we kind
of keep introducing these they're just
going to kind of compound and compound
and compound them on each other so
here's our line on the page put it in an
art gallery what happens if we do it
four times and it's just randomly gone
into an X here but it's kind of yeah
left right left right what happens if we
do it more than four times what happens
we do it more than that what times if we
do it more than that what happens if we
do it more than that this is generative
art this is something now that is going
to be different every single time that
you refresh the page and to me this
looks great this is a kind of oh I've
made something here in a sense it's
finished I've got a finished work I've
got a finished piece of some code that I
made that I'm gonna be able to draw on
in the past and I'm just drawing lines
and tiling right you can do it with a
vertical and horizontal lines and again
we're gonna get a totally different
creation here but again it kind of
provides this weird like mathematical
beauty that I that I really
enjoy so let's start adding some more
techniques to our tool belt displacement
is the second one so say we had these
horizontal lines on the page and each
horizontal line was a connection of
points and we're kind of drawing the
lines through those points so what
happens if we start displacing those
points what if we move their x and y
coordinates around into into a jumble
and we'll take away the dots just to
give the example so we have some kind of
messed up lines on a page but in a sense
that is generative odd in a simple way
but we can start to add kind of logic to
these things and play with them we can
get more complex what if we said
although all the lines to the furthest
left and to the furthest bottom will
start to distort more this is kind of
like a generative art piece you've used
your brain you've kind of used some some
similar techniques but again we're just
drawing lines on the page we can get
more and more complex with something
like this and it's a beauty and again
it's something I'm just going to keep
saying and over and over again I really
love this kind of stuff I really
appreciate it
this is kind of a mimic of an end as
Hough I put a lot of a lot of references
to a lot of generate about us and I
include them all in the end so here we
have three things and all we're really
doing is lines displacement and tiling
so what happens you know what we've got
a line what is the next most complex
thing naturally it's a curve so what
happens if we add curves in JavaScript
to a curve it's almost exactly the same
you have a start and you have an end
position and then you have two control
points and those are used to affect the
curve I actually felt this was really
fun to play with so I thought I'd make
an example that the top right there or
the top left for everybody and the other
side of the start and end point and then
the two other things are the other
control points and you can kind of watch
as that center line would draw the curve
in and and and this is cool because this
is how Bezier curves work it's like whoa
you know you can see the the
interpolation between between each of
the parts which I find super cool and
it's like oh man let's just add 800
points to this whoa fun-fun-fun
it's like oh there's those fuzzy curves
crazy right
so if we add curves to our page and we
go ah let's look back at our tiling
technique and we tile and we Thailand we
tile and we tile you don't even know
that that's what you're gonna get you
don't expect that coming through but
again it's gonna be different
time it's a nice little piece of art
it's a nice little piece of code it's a
nice little rap you know so we can add
curves to our and as half example and
we're starting to get something have
developed a little bit more here and of
course you could put the put the
displacement in the middle and you could
get something like that Joy Division
logo and it's going to be different
every single time so let's add something
else to our page to about repetition and
repetition in development is pretty much
loops right so let's have a play with
those what if we draw our displace line
right across the page and what if we
displace it and draw it again but we
don't erase the previous version and
again and again and again and again and
again and again and again and again we
start to get some kind of patterns
emerging right what happens if we do it
thousands of times we get this kind of
weird natural kind of Harry Harry
creation and you don't really expect
this again it's kind of a little bit of
surprise and delight in your own code
and every single time that you do this
you're going to get something different
a different creation and it's always
going to be cool it's always going to be
different and that's repetition again we
can put that in our and as often now
we've got some really complex stuff
going on here and again it's just
beautiful beautiful little creation so
now we've got eight things that we've
made with with our with our techniques
and you can kind of see what's happening
here and how it's kind of compounding on
itself so shapes let's add shapes we've
got lines curves naturally the next
thing is shapes and again in JavaScript
there's rect and arced so you can do
rectangles and squares and arcs or
circles but really you can draw any
shape you just have to move to each
coordinate of the shape and then say
stroke at the end so if we introduce our
tiling example before and we kind of use
a series of squares and triangles and
circles and stuff like that we're gonna
get again super complex pieces I guess
you can kind of keep going deeper and
you're gonna get this kind of noise
effect we can get these squares and we
can start to apply our displacement in
our random variables so what happens if
we kind of randomly rotate squares that
are that are more towards the bottom
this is a again an example from 1977 or
something like that and what happens if
we displace those we've got this nice
little piece of odd here it can be as
simple or it can be as complex as we
want but again it's
kind of code complete you've got
something you've created something we
can play with a suckle and we can do our
displacement again so there's our dots
and we can start to kind of mangle the
circle around that's what it looks like
and again we can just do it over and
over and over and over again and we're
gonna get this crazy like ring esque
thing form and it's just so much fun to
make this stuff it's so much it adds so
much joy to the code because you again
you're gonna get something different
every single time and it's gonna look
beautiful over and over and over again
so let's add recursion to our tool belt
we all know recursion from coding
interviews and that's pretty much it
but for those who don't know in in
recursion you're calling a function
within itself and then you kind of have
an edge case which is there where it's
like oh let's break out of the break out
of the recursion so in this example I'm
drawing a rectangle and then inside that
rect Kong ago I'm gonna draw another one
until it gets smaller and smaller and
smaller until it reaches a certain size
and then we can start adding in our
random variables again it can be it can
be less complex it can be more complex
we could tilt it in different directions
right and then we can go back to our
tool belt and say Oh what do we know how
to do oh we have tiling right so let's
tile that a bunch of times let's title
it a ton of times and again whoa
something done something really really
nice you can kind of print it out you
can get these AXI drills which will draw
it on a page they're beautiful creations
this again is something from the early
days of computer art we can get a
triangle and we can recurse in that so
if we draw three triangles and then go
another lady and another lady this is
the Pinsky's triangle which is a kind of
common occurrence in in recursion and
then we can add our displacement from
our tool belt we can start messing it
around drawing it again and again and
again we can draw it a ton of times
we're gonna have again these same
effects these same little developments
just kind of going on and on and on and
on this is another one branching which
you wish you kind of see so it splits
into two branches and they go in a
random direction for branches and it
gets more and more complex as you go on
and then we could use our tiling maybe
we could tile them around in a circle
really complex with that and we're going
to have this kind of scary
Mordor eye thing going on
so now look at what we've got like it's
just growing and growing and growing
it's so exciting and it's so fun to just
make this stuff let's add colors to r21
oh my god how do we go this far without
adding colors let's kind of dip into
colors a little bit
Deanna kind of talked about these things
in in her talk in the earlier days
getting random colors is kind of
difficult you would guess oh we got an
our G and a B so let's just kind of
randomize those numbers but you kind of
noticed that we get some of these Genki
colors randomizing and
computer-generated colors is really
really difficult I think that a lot of
generative artists do is they stick to
the HSL space so they can pick a
saturation and a lightness and then you
can rotate through the hue and at least
this way you kind of get similar colors
and it works well for gradients but
again the reality of it is that picking
colors is super complex and there's all
these kind of techniques that people use
but even then it's not really perfect to
the eye so a good trick is really to
just go on a website like Adobe colors
or color levers comb and just find some
nice palettes that people have kind of
put together that you know gonna look
nice and so we can start adding colors
into our examples what if we add it into
our shapes like look at that it's
completely different from the black and
white version it's completely completely
nice this is an example that I took from
a website rectangle world we're drawing
curved lines which are our pipes and we
can kind of get the more and more
complex and they kind of interweave with
each other but when we add color we
start to get these really nice little
creations and you can add like kind of
random colors like this and a palette or
you could do something like this which
is just like one straight red line you
start to add the colors and you start to
get more complexity and more enjoyment
and you can create yeah 800 versions
here's using our circle and we're just
kind of tiling it across the screen
using repetition over and over and you
see it starts to create these kind of
silky these silky effects and we can add
different colors and we can add
different shapes and I don't know it's
just the evolution of it and the beauty
of it it's very kind of screen saver
esque of course as well you see things
like that in screen savers we can go
with our recursion so here's an example
where I'm drawing a circle in a circle
and a circle in a circle what happens if
we draw two circles we start to get this
kind of crazy shape if we draw
three funnily enough the Pinsky's
triangle pops up again but you can see
the kind of complexity evolving in this
and that really all we're doing is
drawing a circle if we draw four if we
draw five like wow you would never
expect something like that to pop out
six it starts to you start to lose a bit
of definition around there but what if
we had colors into that and we use
different shades of green again it's
like oh you start to get these crazy
kind of fractally patterns and you can
you know add a the generative aspect and
kind of be random with with variables
and what you get out of things like that
super beautiful algorithms I'm and we're
starting to get a little bit more
complex here we all know that algorithms
are the world programs use when they
don't want to explain what they did and
that's exactly what I'm gonna do so
Perlin noise is one that pops up a lot I
took this one from code pen I mean a
reference at the end and a purlin noise
you create a field of vectors and
they're pointing in each direction and
then you shoot something through those
vectors and they're influenced by the
world around them Poland noise was
actually created for for animation to
mimic kind of real life examples and
when you put a pearl in noise and you
put a ton of particles you start to get
these really really beautiful
collections creations and it's all it's
all generative on every single time that
you refresh it you're gonna get
something new you're gonna get something
different
you can run them slow you can run them
fast a lot of people kind of pause these
because yeah they have an innate beauty
in their own put them in Asarco they
look really nice printed on shirts and
things like that it's the kind of thing
that looks really really nice when you
start to add color to it and you see
this kind of slowly slowly evolved move
my mouse out of the way yeah the
complexity is just kind of hidden in
this red one might be a little bit more
a little bit more visible it's got this
kind of wood s grain effect and you
could run it longer you can run it
shorter you know it's totally up to you
that's the fun so we can start to add
other inputs into this for example if we
took the Mona Lisa and we said let's
draw a grid across the screen and get
the colors out of each of those spots
and then draw a circle we're gonna get
this nice kind of minimal Mona Lisa
isn't that nice
you could use recursion into that and
georgiana
you're gonna get a different arty style
every time you refresh it's gonna be
different you can turn it into Lego
blocks if you want and it still has a
beautiful style a beautiful feel it's
something that I feel proud to have made
you can add audio inputs and you know
send a message to somebody and save that
out and go hey we've got we've got some
more generative art here so now look at
everything we've made and you can just
see how these simple techniques the
lines the circles they they compound on
themselves and this is really just the
tip of the iceberg for generative art it
just goes on and on and on like this
there's so much to do and so much to add
there's a 3d space that you can enter
there's so much music that goes on that
has kind of generative aspects to it
yeah it just is a super super expensive
beautiful space so I want to get
retrospective for a little bit now that
I've kind of gone through this
techniques and look at what I was
discovering when I was doing this and
I'm running a workshop tomorrow at
decompress to create generative art with
people and it just gave me a nice look
into again the tool belt and the idea
that when we're building things we have
small pieces like drawing a line and we
can put a line and a loop together and
we can create something infinitely
complex but you could also kind of do it
on pen and paper so I wanted to look at
the ways that we learn of course we use
things like tutorials we use things like
Stack Overflow we use things like ducks
and these are great they're they're
really good at providing a small piece
of information that we can use and a lot
of the time I find when when beginners
especially are looking at problems it's
easy to get a little bit confused with
what they're trying to do and what is
the actual problem at hand we have
things like code pen jsbin jsfiddle
glitch is one of the new ones that that
provide us with a way to give examples
to each other and and through these
examples we can kind of add it through
and see what people have done we have
awesome things
Suz here does twitch streaming of live
coding there's websites like the coding
train and clever program at that are
built to show new people new things but
again I guess the way that we look at
learning and the way that we
at developing I was I was kind of hoping
to make something a little bit different
so I started playing around with this
idea or something that I've called
tutorial mock down and I'm using
generative odd as the examples but here
we've got a tutorial that you would see
in a kind of regular everyday site we've
got an iframe and we've got a small kind
of code section at the top and what I
wanted to do is is create this
experience that lets you go at your own
pace but through the kind of medium of
tutorial I'm not like a video where you
have to pull it and go back so as you
scroll through this you're going to
start to see the code kind of riding
itself into the bottom into the top left
and it's executing in the bottom right
so oh we're going to stop by drawing a
line in the tutorial we're going to
explain how a line works we're gonna add
a generative aspect down here so it
could be random every single time like
oh if you don't understand this you can
kind of go back to the the single line
and then we're going to start to add
more complexity and start drawing and
kind of go in and out and say oh you
know I want to I want to go back I want
to play with this you can kind of play
with it so this is something that I've
kind of been working on and the the
style that I'm doing it is fairly simple
it's it's a markdown option have used
the dock on the screen it's just regular
markdown and a few commands so tutorial
markdown set up HTML tutorial markdown
set up styles and then when you're when
you're just writing the code again the
same thing just like a tutorial markdown
trigger and as we'll kind of go through
this will generate into your markdown
and create these interactive tutorials I
don't have anything to release just yet
but kind of keep an eye on that space
and if you're interested even remotely
in working on something like this with
me definitely give me a bell
there's my Twitter thank you very much
you
you